welcome to the stola the stoah is a
digital campfire where equal hear and
dialogue about what matters most at the
night's edge what's happening now
[Music]
all right everyone welcome to the stoah
I'm the Stewart of the stoah Peter
Lindbergh some of you may know I run the
stoic group here in Toronto Canada and
obviously we can't meet right now - did
the situation so I decided to launch the
stoah which I'm a viewing as not just a
space to talk and practice about
stoicism but a place - for us to cohere
and dialogue about what matters most at
the nice edge of this moment and I'm
bringing in a lot of people - to
practice different exercises and to give
talks and today we have a special guest
my friend Greg Sadler
Greg is a a PPA certified philosophical
counselor is the editor of stoicism
today and he's the president of reason
IO which is an organization that puts
philosophy into practice and he's going
to give a talk today on stoic fortitude
and it's gonna be about 20 minutes and
then we're gonna open up to questions a
Q&A and if you have a question for Greg
just write in the chat box and I'll ask
you to unmute yourself and you can read
it or if you want me to read it on your
behalf
just indicate that in the chat that's
that being said I'll hand it over to
Greg thanks Peter and for the invitation
to come into this virtual space and talk
about these things so I am going to talk
about fortitude or the the virtue of
courage but I'm also talking quite a bit
about failure and failings and when when
Peter approached me about what topic I
might want to talk about that's what
came to mind right away because I think
that we don't we don't talk about it
enough in terms of stoicism I know in
our local group we we do every once in a
while bring up where we went wrong and
then we analyze it but there's you know
it's not it's not something that people
are often happy to discuss and it's
really important because any motive
tensional living and install system is
one of those there's gonna be a lot of
failings and a lot of failures so
stoicism helps us to understand those
and to wean ourselves away from
dysfunctional approaches to the
inevitable failures that we have and the
reason why I pick fortitude wasn't just
because you know the alliteration the
nice F sounds or something like that
it's because if we if we look at what
the Stoics actually said about that
virtue of fortitude or courage it's
broader than just dealing with fears and
it really does have some some resources
there to help us deal with the
inevitable failures that we right into
so this is gonna be kind of restricted
in scope there's so much that could be
said about this I think one could
actually write a small book about it
we're going to talk and I've already
used up probably a minute of the time
this is gonna get on some some key
points so you know I talked about why
this this issue and I'll I'll start by
talking about a failing of mine that's
also culminated in several failures for
all of you know if you're not involved
in academia all of your still you know
quite aware that everything has had to
go online and that takes a lot of work
and a lot of thought from this and I've
been teaching online for eight years now
so you know when we first got
quarantined until they we're gonna
extend Spring Break you better start
shifting the classes online that first
weekend I thought oh this is a perfect
opportunity I can like get a lot of this
work done right away and then I found
myself as many of you probably have as
well and this is a topic we could talk
about as well at the end you know
feeling kind of unmotivated feeling kind
of kind of blue and sad and not getting
the things done that I I said I would
and that's you know that's both a
failure but it's also a failing and I'll
talk about the difference between those
in a bit because it's something that I
you know often do more often than I'd
like I create this great Google Calendar
full of things that I'm going to do and
then I don't actually get to them and
then I have to revise it and take stock
of the fact that the work didn't get
done and who does it affect well it
affects my students and it's not like I
left them in the lurch but I wanted to
do all these different things that would
use their transition and keep them from
feeling anxious and I got maybe half of
them done you know on the scale that I
wanted so you know that's sort of a
classic instance I have some duties
towards these people that I have
response with I know what the right
thing is to do and yet I find myself not
getting all of the right thing done and
and I think many of you can bring up
similar instances in in your own just
the last couple weeks the quarantine and
the staying at home and all the
anxieties about koban 19 and the
situation that we're in I think makes
this even more important to talk about
because as we put more stress on the
systems that we live in and we put more
stress upon ourselves we're going to
make more mistakes we're going to shift
into unhealthy ways of looking at things
so let's talk about failings and
failures we often use these words
synonymously as if they're the same
thing and I'm not saying that we have to
be you know grammar police or anything
like that about this but it is useful to
make a distinction we often fail at
things and we do so in determinate ways
within situations that's a failure and
it could be minor it could be I forgot
to take the dog out and so the dog is is
upset you know and maybe has an accident
or something like that and then it has
to be cleaned up and you know
inconveniences people or it could be a
really big thing like I didn't check
into my classes all week and my students
are wondering where where is this guy
what are we going to do and and there's
all sorts of possibilities and then
when we realize that we've failed
sometimes we realize that there's
something more going out there that we
have failings that there's there's
things about ourselves that aren't what
we'd like them to be and you know our
society is very good at giving us all
sorts of sometimes correct and very
often incorrect information about what
our failings would be you might think
about the fashion industry and how it
pushes a certain not just you know
coiffeur and you know set of clothes
that should change every season but body
types and what we ought to be investing
our time and attention into those those
can make us think that we're fail that
we're failing when we're not really
doing so so we can talk about that as
well we also see failings and failures
in other people and one of the things I
think we can be on guard from the
beginning against is interpreting
failures on people's part as
automatically signifying failings on
their part so if I you know neglect an
email for a while and don't respond to
it right away that doesn't mean that
that that failure is automatically
because of a failing with me and not
wanting to address people or being
disrespectful or anything along those
lines but you know we have to be on
guard against that because that's a
natural tendency to read those things
into other people's behavior so in any
as I was saying in any path of
intentional living and personal
development we really want to expect to
fail very often when we're starting it
and you know I know just looking at the
list of people here so let me have been
practicing stoicism for quite a long
time and even then all of those who
can't then you can weigh in and say yeah
we keep on failing as well but when
you're first embracing some stoic
principles and practices you're gonna
fail all the time and you know that's
just part of the course it's just like
learning
musical instrument or going to the gym
and starting a new exercise routine you
know it makes sense that that would
happen and so you know dealing with
failure productively is going to be very
important for us and you know we can
think about some of the ways in which we
fail and I came up with a list here I'm
just gonna like hit on some of the
general ways right some of them are
cognitive we get mixed up in what we
think are assumed or we have incorrect
ideas about things like mixing up what's
in our control and what's what's not in
our control we make mistaken inferences
we follow out automatic lines of thought
processes or lines of reasoning that are
mistaken sometimes we actually just sort
of make a mistake almost like you know
in mathematics would be lined up with
the wrong number at the end we're not
quite sure how we got there we get the
wrong results well we do that with our
reasoning as well but we also have
effective ways in which we fail and this
is where I think service ISM can be
really helpful in telling us what we
what we want to desire and what we ought
to be averse to right
we often desire the wrong things or are
averse to the wrong things or too much
too little we direct our emotions
towards the wrong objects sometimes we
act on them in ways that are not helpful
for us or for others and we often do
realize if we've been thinking about
ourselves and examining ourselves which
is part of stoicism that we we should
feel something better or different but
don't then we feel that as a failure
right on our on our part there's also a
volitional mortalities we we sometimes
choose the wrong things or commit to the
wrong things the bad instead of the good
and then afterwards we said well what
was I thinking there we choose things
that could be good but end up being bad
because we don't pay close enough
attention to what we're doing we start
with a good intention but don't follow
through on it or we prioritize things in
a way that that gets in our own way
Epictetus is term or sometimes we fail
to fulfill the duties that we have and
that leads us into action sometimes when
we have an action we don't follow
through on it we don't check up to see
whether the results actually turned out
the way that we assumed or you know
things turn out differently than we
intended because we we don't act in a
pure vacuum we were within an entire
matrix of causes that include other
people and the universe itself and all
of these these processes and so things
go astray and we have to stay on top of
that so those are all different ways in
which we might experience failure and we
might you know when we bring stoicism
into the mix in a way it kind of raises
the bar so we hold ourselves to higher
standards then we would have had we
would have in the past when it comes to
our choices and actions and thoughts and
particularly to emotions you know for
myself I've struggled my entire life
with anger that's part of how I got into
studying stuff Isis over the first place
so I'm gonna you know the back story I
may I don't be happy to share it the Q&A
if people want and you know the Stoics
are very zero-tolerance when it comes to
ager and I can say I fail at that
probably not every single day but pretty
close and so you know when we we begin
to hold ourselves to higher standards we
become much more conscious of where
we're failing we also do so and I think
there's a very helpful mental construct
when it comes to virtues and vices you
know when we can give a name to ways in
which we don't want to be and is bad for
a person to be and we can give a name to
the ways that we ought to be that would
be good for us to be that helps us to
guide ourselves and and you know we
often fail when it comes to the virtues
the entire realm of duties or
appropriate actions of a Kea in the
Latin our relations to others well we
often fail in those I'll speak for
myself I often do those
maybe some what do you do as well and
stoicism you know reinforces for us hey
you've got all these connections to
other people you really need to pay
attention to them and do the right thing
in in the fabric of those relationships
and you know you might say oh well that
makes you know in that case maybe we
should get rid of stoicism it just makes
us more miserable right it's not
fulfilling its promise of making us
happier and you know we might want to
think about the legendary sage and the
fact that maybe some of you aim to be
the sage I don't I'm a Procope Don and I
intend to be that my entire life because
that's good enough you know
I just want to get a bit better and a
bit better just like epictetus says hey
I don't have to be Socrates it's enough
if I just make some progress along the
way and I think another thing that
Epictetus says is helpful in this all of
you remember that the passage from the
enchiridion about the beginner blames
everybody except for themselves right
and the person who's making some
progress blames himself and then the
person who's actually made a lot of
progress or understands things doesn't
blame anybody and we use this as a class
of a Qatari principle I think we should
see this as a continuum instead you know
as a process where we wean ourselves
away from blaming other people and we
start focusing more on what we need to
change in ourselves and what we need to
be you know sometimes hard on ourselves
about and then eventually move away from
that as well doesn't mean that we're
ever going to get there
entirely and not blame anybody and be
totally cool with everything that's
going on maybe that's not not what we
need to do another thing I wanted to
talk about is common mistakes that
people make when they fail and how we
can look at them from a stoic
perspective and I think looking at them
from the stoic perspective will happen
more in the Q&A but here's some common
mistakes and you can add your own as
well so the first one is denying that
there was any failure in the first place
right it didn't happen and then you know
all of you are familiar with them the
path well it didn't happen
oh it did happen but I you know wasn't
me
or was me but I didn't intend it oh I
did intend it but it really didn't have
the bad effect that that you're saying
it that you know all this minimizing
that goes out that is not helpful at all
right
if we fail who we need to actually
acknowledge that we did fail another big
problem that people launch themselves
into a rather set of problems and
actually when I was thinking about this
I realized this is a very common theme
in sitcoms a person will fail at
something and then they will try to fix
it by any means they can and they don't
they don't approach it attentively they
don't approach it with proce okay as we
would say in stoicism they're reacting
immediately and the efforts that they
make make it worse and worse and worse
worse until around the you know 28
minute mark everything falls apart and
then we have a nice you know coming
together and we learned a lesson sort of
thing
well you know in real life this this
approach towards failure often doesn't
pay off that way
shifting responsibilities to others
that's another problematic way of
dealing with failure we we actually need
to deal with things that are our
business the things that are up to us
ignoring how we make things harder for
others when we fail that's that's
another common thing as well and I think
if we're Stoics we have to think about
larger systems that were involved so
like you know for example if I didn't
show up until 20 minutes into this I
would be putting out however many people
are I can't I can't tell exactly right
now every many people were waiting for
this right if I let if I fail myself I
let others down sometimes and that's a
matter of justice in a matter of Duty's
another thing that often happens when
people fail is excessive emotional
reactions and sometimes this can be you
know guilt or shame sadness is a common
one anxiety you know what if people
think I'm a bad person because of this
some of the other ones that come up that
maybe you don't experience but I know I
do frustration that leads to anger and
then lashing out at others which
generates yet another failure or even a
desire and enjoyment and seeing others
fail so that least it you know detracts
from from what you're doing another
another common mistake I think is being
too concerned about what other people
will think and not about what you're
actually dealing with in the situation
so how can we approach these things as a
stoic I think one of the most helpful
principles is the dichotomy of control
you know thinking about what is
genuinely up to us and what isn't up to
us and one thing that we definitely
don't control is whether we failed or
not so you know once we fail that is set
and that's there in the past and we can
tell whatever story as we want about it
and we can reframe things in more
productive ways but the thing happened
and if it came from something within us
a failure within us that's still there
too and you know we can change how we
approach it in the future but we really
can't do much more than that
we will have failings and failures with
respect to all sorts of things that are
indifference and you know those in fact
do matter as Epictetus tells us the
things that are in difference like say
money it doesn't have no value
whatsoever it just doesn't have the
value that a lot of people ascribe to it
and how we use it is important and is up
to us so we can think about those those
you know classifications prudence has to
do with how we use indifference in large
part same thing with justice the same
thing with fortitude and we probably
should try to work on our skills and
abilities that we call virtues it will
help us deal well with the
indifference so I think that's one key
thing you know we look at what is in our
control and we you know focus on a mat
but we also try to maintain some focus
on what we don't absolutely control but
can influence in some way and we should
do that well another thing is being
concerned about as I mentioned what
other people make of our failures and
Marcus has a thing that he says at one
point epictetus I believe has another
thing in seneca has something similar
where somebody's criticizing somebody
else and they say well obviously you
don't know me that well because if you
did you know not only would you
criticize me for this one thing over
here that I fail that boy you'd see all
these other things where I'm screwing up
as well and doing that can kinda help
you put things in perspective I'm not
saying you can say that to everybody
but you can sort of say that to yourself
in your mind and then maybe not feel as
as bad about the single thing that it's
weighing upon you realism about success
rates is also very important you know
Socrates himself has that makita's tells
us went around and this is his divine
mission in Epictetus --is of you to go
around and tell people focus on your
soul don't worry so much on these other
things and what was his success rate
about one in a thousand so if Socrates
himself was not succeeding all of the
time maybe we need to adjust downward
depending on what it is our conception
what success and failure are maybe some
of the things that we think of as
failures partly failures and you could
say well in that case we go back to the
dichotomy of control all Socrates could
do is put the message out there and you
know in a very assertive way which got
him killed eventually but it's up to the
other people to take that into account
and that's not up to him
we can also think about what we learn
from failures as experiences experiences
our appearances fantasy I for christos
ISM which doesn't mean that they have no
reality whatsoever even reason itself
the Faculty of reason is a system of
appearances Epictetus tells us so we
need to look at how things are connected
with each other and whether we're
getting them right cognitively and
effectively the last thing I would say
you know that might be helpful from a
stoic perspective and this is not just
there in stoic advice but it runs
throughout intentional modes of living
is that we can't hope to fix everything
at once if we do here if we discover
failings in ourselves we have to work on
them bit by bit so if I'm you know
struggling to not drink you know two
pots of coffee a day which I'm not going
to change by the way
oh that's that's my normal consumption
there's there's other things I could
focus on more like you know what my
students need for me but if I decided to
make that my focus
I probably shouldn't try to do
everything else at the same time and we
can remind ourselves what is the goal of
stoic philosophy so the stock answers
are you getting more Nia right good flow
of life and tranquility how do we
actually do that what does that actually
look like the Stoics tell us this is
where we get to the nitty-gritty of it
then it means understanding and choosing
and actually doing the things that we're
supposed to do appropriate actions or
duties they also tell us an Epictetus
it's like constantly stressing this that
the goal of the stomach life is to
recognize where we are in conflict with
ourselves where we are contradictions
the Greek word for that is my literally
battle where we're fighting ourselves
and to work through that gradually
untangling these knots that we have
within ourselves they also think that we
are truth seeking animals we want to
know reality we don't want to be
screwing up health it's like in our
assessing things so we have to be very
realistic about the world and very
realistic about ourselves that means
seeing where we're feeling and stoic
philosophy is about a progressive
transformation of the person it's not
about an on/off switch where we learn
some principles and now everything turns
into happiness and and tranquility
instead we have to do some work and so
here's where we get to fortitude and I
realize I'm already going a little bit
long so I'm going to keep this fairly
short so fortitude is a virtue right we
often translated as courage in Latin its
fortitude fortitudo and in Greek it's on
delay I and like the other for the other
three cardinal virtues it's an
overarching basket of things so what
does it encompass it does include the
traditional notion of like dealing with
fear for anxiety right being brave in
the face of danger or stuff like that
but it encompasses more for the Stoics
so Cicero tells us in on duties that
fear is one of the emotions that it
helps us to handle desire is another and
anger is another as well those all fall
within the scope of this area's didymus
who you know if you haven't checked him
out he's worth he's worth taking a look
at he gave this epitome of stoic ethics
he talks about these five different
aspects to courage or fortitude
so in Greek I'll give you the Greek
terms and I'll tell you what they mean
and I'll give you his gloss on them
because he doesn't go much further than
that so the first one is car tyria and
this week we translate his perseverance
but also as endurance depending on which
translation you're looking at and he
calls this the knowledge there they're
all types of knowledge a piston a but
they're not like just purely cognitive
they're also you know with within our
habits and and our feelings this is a
knowledge that that is ready to remain
and what is right then rightly decided
so when we've decided we want to do X
perseverance helps us to do that that's
part of what it means to be courageous
in this respect
so being courageous doesn't have to be
running into the burning building it
could be actually doing the things that
you said you were going to do washing
all the dishes instead of saying well
we'll do them in the morgue you know to
take a sort of trivial example another
one that's a little bit closer to like
the the feeling of courage is thought
early Oh tastes intrepid Ness it's
related to the word for confidence and
he says this is the knowledge through
which we know we will not encounter
anything terrible we can really realize
that we're up to the challenges in front
of us
even if they happen to be you know like
dealing with this terrible illness
that's going on another one that they
said fits into that is McCallum sukhiya
which is often translated as great soul
in Nisour magnanimity Aristotle treats
it as a separate virtually the Stoics
thought that fit under courage and it's
a rising above it's rising above and
sort of looking at things from that
perspective so it helps us put things
into perspective and he says it doesn't
just apply to trivial stuff it also
applies to the stuff that's genuinely
valuable so we realize that you know it
is valuable for us to have certain
relationships but if we have to let
those go in order to accomplish it yet
greater good then we do that another one
is what he calls you Sophia
stout-hearted miss this is something I
think a lot of people are attracted to
in stoicism its knowledge belonging to
the soul and grasping itself is
unconquered reminding ourselves that we
do get to decide we are the ones who
determine what we're going to do with
ourselves and our faculties and our
abilities and then the final one that I
particularly like is called Philip onea
literally meaning loving toil or loving
difficult things and so this is
translated as industrious Nisour
diligence it means being able to
accomplish what's proposed without being
prevented by the toil that's involved
and this is where like you know we get
reluctant sometimes we encounter things
or like yeah I've got this great idea
this intention
and then you know it gets kind of late
at night we're tired and we're like oh
I'll do that later
and then it doesn't happen that's a
failing right and so by being
industrious we can not just keep
ourselves from doing that but we can
return back to what we need to do
Epictetus doesn't talk about courage
much but he does talk about all these
parts he doesn't use the word virtue
very often now becker himself i think
many of you know his new stoicism he
summarizes these in three things courage
endurance and perseverance but it covers
a lot of the same ground and he says
that we need these in order to be able
to exercise our agency that we ought to
have so you know this I think maybe it's
sort of like a little pep talk more than
a deep analysis or anything like that
but it gives you an idea about how we
can use this this virtue fortitude to
approach the inevitable failing failures
that we we see and then the failings
within us that we want to work on the
last thing I'll say is you know the
Stoics are often portrayed as saying
that virtue is just a kind of knowledge
right and that's true they do think that
there's a cognitive side too it's not
just you know having an automatic
response you do need to know what you're
doing and you do to think about it and
you do need attentiveness
Epictetus talks about us is having the
virtues within us as sort of resources
that we can draw upon and that's another
aspect to it these are all part of our
nature if we choose to develop it but
the other thing where the Stoics do line
up with other virtue ethicists is their
emphasis on if we want to actually have
the virtues available to us if we want
to have fortitude we have to continually
choose and practice and that leads to
establishing new habits that is going to
happen over time and there's sort of a
meta level here we're going to fail at
that too and so we have to be willing to
you know if we want to use more of the
imagery like the wrestler pick himself
up dust himself off and get back
ring again and fortitude is the virtue
that helps us do that so fortitude
develops itself in its own practice and
the last thing I'll close on is just
saying well if you do this it gets
better it gets easier I'm saying that
from somebody who's gone a bit of the
way and can see you know further on the
horizon probably some of you are further
along with that than I am but you know
the message is you can do this you can
deal with failings and failures and it's
okay it's in one respect it's okay to
fail because you're going to and you
have to become okay with it obviously
you don't want to fail less but you want
to be quite realistic with yourself
about what's going on so fortitude is
the thing that we need to focus on that
that's that's my stick here so I'll open
it up to Q&A cool cool
so if you have any questions write it to
Greg in the chat box and I'll calling
you Tony yourself or I'll read on your
behalf and I'll warm up Greg right now
with the question of my own or me well
I'll share some thoughts and then maybe
we can tease out a question here yeah so
what was salient is when you mentioned
the the sitcom thing because my wife and
I just finished watching the whole
series of friends and I had a Jason
thought similar to that that I noticed
everyone freaking lies in every episode
they're lying
same thing with signs are always lying
and and you're right the lying stems
from some minor mistake or failure or
whatever and then they make it worse by
lying right and if they were just being
upfront and forthright and truthful then
there wouldn't be an episode essentially
and what comes to mind is Jordan Hall
had his take on wisdom is being in the
right relationship with reality which
could do another spin of like living in
accordance with nature and so the
thought came to mind like what is right
relationship with failure you know it's
similar what you're talking about so I
just throw that out you if you think
that's a helpful framework for anything
came to mind yeah and as I mentioned you
know the Stoics think of us as animals
that have these sort of basic drives
toward
and unlike the other ones we have a
drive towards truth and that's where the
the virtual wisdom hits its beginnings
from according to Cicero who's just you
know essentially telling us what Cato
said so kind of orthodox stoic teaching
in that case and and I think that's
completely right we want to have a
veridical relationship with reality and
we're part of reality so we want to
understand ourselves and sometimes part
of so sometimes that can be a very
painful truth to see right you know oh I
thought I had all my hangers stuff done
and then we start you know talking about
recipes and somehow we get into you know
shouting at each other or something like
yeah well there's a sign that things are
not as I thought they were you know it's
kind of funny with the sitcom thing is
you're attacking about that we're fans
of Corinth uzi azzam and Larry David is
like he's an epitome of this he's sort
of a you know kind of stoic about stuff
of the lowercase s it doesn't matter
right but he's constantly screwing
things up worse and worse worse by
making a bad decision and then trying to
cover it up in some way yeah you know
the notion that we could somehow fix
things by lying okay that's a false
thing right so being wise would be
realizing among other things realizing
that you can't fix things just by
telling people some sort of story to
mollify them but you you have to fix the
relationship so now and that's probably
you know in some respects too messy and
boring to make good TV yeah
so we'll move it to the the questions
and thus I would like me to read this so
how do you apply this view to the
failures versus failings of other people
seems a relevant aspect in a time when
many are eager to criticize others
reactions or lack of reaction in the
face of crisis yeah that's that's a
great question and so we can talk about
that in a number of different ways you
know we can talk about how one one
interprets it oneself and
whether you know whether you're doing
the right thing you could say in
relation to other people's failings
which most of the time is going to be
not talking about them ignoring them
because it's not your business you know
I get on Twitter and Twitter is kind of
a great place for everybody getting up
in each other's business because you
know even the people the people who you
follow are bringing other people into
your stream and there might be a
temptation to correct people or I'll say
oh you're totally mistaken about this
this sort of thing and I think as a
stoic you would you would want to think
well is it really worth my time to get
involved in this particular situation
this particular tip now if we're talking
about people closer to us maybe those
who we have responsibility for so like
you know if my kids are doing something
that's not to their benefit or might be
harming others I probably should say
something to them about that and maybe
even if I have of any any sway in the
situation because you know quite often
kids are you know they really are their
own thing their own little world try to
influence them and bring them towards
what's good and we could say this maybe
you know you think about this I hadn't
thought about this before but you know
think about the concentric circles that
we talked about with here achlys and we
usually bring this up in terms of Winkie
osis and you know like loving everybody
ultimately out to the ends of the earth
and all the human you know but but
there's also that that more inner circle
where we are more concerned with them
and we probably in times like this
probably should pay closer attention I
need to focus for example on my students
I don't need to really worry about what
my Dean is doing even if the policies
that there are doing seem a little bit
counterproductive I need to focus more
on my tasks there will be some people's
failures that are going to be bad in
many respects for other people
and you know the most we can do often is
hey you're screwing up here would be a
better path but you know right now well
so we you know let's talk about the
colvett 19 crisis most countries have
some sort of unified response at this
point in time here in the United States
we don't it's been left up to the
individual state it's in some of the
individual states left about to
individual municipalities and so you
know there have been some very imprudent
decisions made in recent times and we're
going to suffer the consequences for
them and you know strictly speaking
these have to do with what the Stoics
would call indifference you know being
healthier sick wealthy you know we're
looking at economic collapse in many
cases or poor but indifference do matter
and we we shouldn't just you know say
hello or stomachs so long as it doesn't
affect my own virtue or vice you know I
think it's okay to be critical of
inadequate responses but you know here
we can talk about man or how do we do
that do we allow ourselves to get all
angry and worked up about it
do we start calling people names how you
know how do we do it you know
sonica himself this is a bit of a side
note says that in some cases even though
you're not angry it could be useful to
look angry if you're dealing with people
who only understand that that point of
view he talks about a judge displaying
anger towards a a criminal defendant and
you know maybe our legislators only get
you know when we seem upset with them
but that doesn't mean that we actually
have to be upset
so that's kind of a long-winded answer
so next question and just a disclaimer
other questions we might not get to all
the questions and I'm not gonna be
reading an order I'm gonna use my
discernment to kind of like yes and the
previous thing Gregg said so uh Alex so
you have a question for Gregg would you
like to go off from you and ask it
[Music]
Alex I'll unmute you if you like yeah
you're unmuted
okay thanks Peter thanks for your
presentation um I was wondering about
fear and stroke and stoicism and the
virtue of courage specifically I guess
I'm wondering what happens when a person
acts courageously the sphere disappear
completely or is it just somehow
transformed and managed you know just
puts it under our control because I've
read I've read that for the Stoics you
know like the stoic sage lives without
any fear at all
and I know for somebody like Aristotle
you know fear is always going to be
there and it's just a matter of kind of
managing it well so yes for Aristotle
this that's not actually the case and
Aristotle's closer to the Stoics on this
Aristotle says that the courageous
person will feel fear in the face of
things that are genuinely fearful but
they're not going to feel fear when they
when it doesn't make sense to feel it
the way somebody who say has a phobia
does right so you know if you're if
you're in the Mediterranean in the
ancient world on a ship and you're in
the middle of a storm it and you and
you're the the poor guy who's got to go
up above and like secure the things that
are otherwise going to move around that
makes sense to be scared okay
but you master you try to master the
fear and not allow it to dominate you so
you can do the right thing and the
Stoics have a similar thing so in some
cases it will mean not feeling fear and
this is where the cognitive side comes
in if you understand that some things
aren't really scary even though people
say that they are or your first reaction
is to think that they are you can you
can avoid feeling fear but even even
though the stomach philosophy we all
talk about sages but even the stoic
philosopher
is going to have these these free
emotions where the body just kind of you
know reacts to things maybe the
adrenaline starts flowing and they
manage it but there will be some things
that will be genuinely scary and this is
where I guess I'm tempted to think that
modern stoicism would acknowledge a
wider range of the Stoics had with what
are called you path I write the good
emotions the good emotional states and
caution you LA baya is one of those and
that's feeling fear when it's rational
to feel fear I think maybe we would be a
little bit more wide in our scope so you
know for example my kids are down in
Indiana right now they're separated from
from me by two states and I know that
they're doing okay living out in the
countryside but I can still feel some
concern for them and now does that have
to look rise to the level of something
where I'm calling them up all the time
or texting them how are you doing you
know you're not coughing or yet or
anything like that
right no I did that that would be
clearly off base but exhibiting what the
Stoics called caution you know that does
make sense in a lot of cases and you
know so if we let's think of very
practical terms we live in an apartment
complex here and I have a wife who's
immune compromised we have quite a few
younger people living in the complex who
seemed rather cavalier about contagion
and social distancing and things like
that and you know we have to be careful
we have to be cautious about that
[Music]
so there will be some things where you
know somebody wants to get on the
elevator with me my reaction is don't
take the next elevator buddy you know
and it may seem kind of rude and I can
do that without feeling you know oh this
thing's the thing gripping me this fear
and my gut but it but it is still within
the same affective domain and if I see
somebody doing something really dumb you
know like I don't licking the elevator
buttons I should I should feel some
sense of you know like the hairs on the
back of my neck could make up something
there's really wrong there that's kind
of a silly an example but if you get
what I'm saying all right so so there's
there's kind of a complex spectrum you
could say in some cases it's going to
keep you from feeling fear at all
because you've realized this isn't
really something scary in other cases it
will be though the more it seems more
Aristotelian but it is also equally
stoic to work despite the fact that
you're feeling fear so Ben had a
question he'd like me to read it for him
how does the stoic concept of fortitude
relate to or differ from modern notions
of resilience and anti fragility I would
say there's a lot of overlap there the
notion of resilience is is one of those
things where you ask you know ten
experts and you get ten different
answers about what exactly a consistent
so I think we'd have to pin down what
what a person precisely means by it I
think it covers a lot of the same ground
since what we're talking about here is
perseverance and industriousness and
maybe some of what they they called you
know the McCall sukhiya or you know what
being able to rise above things because
that means being able to put things in
in perspective the antifragility thing
is kind of an interesting take to think
about particularly in terms of the how
we was you know how we bounce back from
failure right so anti fragile things
aren't perfect and they're not like
armored against everything else but and
they and they take some damage and
sometimes even real trauma but they're
able to
you know sort of self organize and
reorganize in ways that then make them
stronger as a result and so with with
that describe what a stoic courageous
response would be when you actually fail
I think it probably would so I think
that could be a helpful helpful
criterion are we making ourselves more
as persons more anti fragile by the way
in which we're approaching our failures
I mean the opposite would be oh I failed
on everything's everything's doom and
gloom I'll never be able to like show my
face or do anything again that's that's
you know not just a lack of resiliency
that's also being gradual right you're
completely shattered and you know it's
it's interesting that you ask that too
because you know we're going to come
back from this crisis and things are
going to be changed in so many ways
some of them for the worst some of them
for the better and it's going to be in
response to what we go through
I mean we're you know the more more
pessimistic predictions are we're only
in the very beginning of our self
quarantine and social isolation and
stuff like that we might be going on for
months and months and months and you
know the economy is going to look quite
different when we're when we're finished
with this there's going to be a lot of
you know my wife has a lot of
connections in the food and restaurant
industry they're really hurting right
now you know a lot of restaurants are
going to go under and what's going to be
left after we're done we'll have to see
how how the whole industry is able to
bounce back and when I say that whole
industry I mean all these other people
whose livelihoods are dependent upon it
many people beautiful it's their
entry-level jobs so you know I guess
we'll see which systems are actually
anti fragile as well
stoic Dan and you had a question feel
free to unmute yourself oh I think I
might have to yeah yet you can unmute
yourself now Dan thank you um earlier in
your talk Greg you mentioned that Stoics
have a zero tolerance to anger and
that's usually the way I would describe
it as well but just yesterday I was
listening to Massimo talk on another
call like this and he said that
sometimes a stoic will need to show
anger to snap someone into doing the
right thing kind of like that rare
oddity that we sometimes hear about a
buddhist teacher slapping his student so
oh but massimo added that you should not
feel anger inside you should only
display it and this should be rare what
do you think about that that's exactly
what Seneca said that's that's the
example in on anger of the judge who
appears to be angry so displays you know
they don't display anger in the sense of
acting from anger within them they
display the conventional appearance of
anger like raising their voice and you
know maybe like they make themself get
red in the face or something like that
we can imagine so that's you know that's
pretty straightforward there is actually
a debate about going on right now about
well maybe the aristotelian oh the
Stoics by the way misrepresented I'll
mention as well if we look at that the
ancient you know taxes and stuff like
that a little bit on that this maybe
they were civilians were or a bit right
in thinking that anger would be needed
to galvanize people to doing what's
right you know on a larger scale in
terms of getting our politicians to take
the dangers to working-class people and
I mean here's a great example here in
Milwaukee we've had 10 deaths now and
all of them have been on the north side
of Milwaukee and the poor neighborhoods
so there's clearly you know some some
things that need to be attended to and I
think it you know could anger get the
politicians to pay more attention to
public health things yeah the problem is
that when we use anger for activism like
like Seneca and Aristotle point out
anger gets away from you really easily
it's kind of a blunt instrument and so
Seneca says anything that we could
accomplish with anger we could
accomplish just by following right
practical reasoning and so you know
whether or not we can get mass movements
going without it I don't know that we
can certainly as individuals act
appropriately without using anger so if
I see my child being bullied
anger could spur me to take a stand
against that but it could also lead me
to like you know going over and punching
the bullying kids dad in the face or
something like that and we don't want
those sorts of excessive reaction so
anger is anger is always kind of
dangerous even if we think a little bit
could be okay
you know if we want to use that meme we
can have a little bit of anger as a
treat sometime no you know it's still
kind of kind of dangerous to do that
okay so we have time for one more
question okay let's do this one so this
is from Greg Lopez our friend from New
York so Epictetus asked us to transfer a
versions from externals to our internal
state what's the balance of blaming
yourself without also inflaming
secondary passions about how you have a
failing can you give an example of how
you do it okay that's that's a good one
and and yeah epic you dissing in the
enchiridion suggests transferring
aversions entirely from from externals I
think some of the stuff he says in the
discourse is modifies that but let's say
that we're actually doing this so we're
trying to focus entirely inward on our
own
and we could look at it as failings
right so we should be averse to being
unless let's use it in terms of the
virtues right let's say we're we realize
that we're a little greedy and that
means that we want to take more than our
fair share of things which then leaves
other people in the lurch it could be
like toilet paper for example right and
Hawaii pretty in this crisis I don't
know if that's been happening in Canada
but it's a big problem here in the
States
for some reason it's an only crisis
where we've actually seen this this
weird behavior with toilet paper so you
know you you you realize that you're
getting caught up in the hysteria about
how we better get out and get as many
rolls as possible
now you instead of being averse to not
having toilet paper if we're following
you know potatoes they'd be averse to
being the kind of jerk who goes out and
and takes what other people need and
hoards it up and then now that would
require us to like look at what's going
on with me what's wrong with me that I
do this sort of thing and now we start
to carry out some analysis and so
there's you know what's going to help us
doing that is it like you know beating
our breasts and say may I cold but no
that's that's not particularly
productive as a matter of fact some
people do that sort of thing precisely
so they don't have to engage in self
analysis they feel like they've gotten
himself off of the you know the the
charge that they were involved in before
we'd have to actually look well why am I
so concerned about having this one
commodity what am I afraid of what am I
being averse to so now we're we're
engaging in introspection and we're
using through stoic categories to do
that now how would we avoid not blaming
ourselves in other ways there's a
blaming yourself like getting yourself
off the hook for doing that which is
just a show but what about actually
feeling oh I'm a really bad person for
doing this that's not going to be
particularly productive either how do we
how do we avoid that we could say to
herself things like well you know
I screwed up and my screwing up makes
sense given the things that I know about
myself it's not a good thing for me to
do this and I'd like to move away from
this but I don't have to like you know
self lacerate in order to to get past
this or there might be other emotions
too like anger directed at other people
and all those those other people who
made me do this no the other people
didn't make you do that you you know you
have a prior ASUS you have your own
Faculty of choice you decided to allow
yourself to get caught up in the toilet
paper hoarding hysteria so can I give an
example of how I do it I mean hopefully
the toilet paper one gives an example
but and could we think about other ways
that aren't quite so silly
that we can do this and other secondary
passions
you know maybe so one interesting one
and this is where we move where stoicism
and existentialism could overlap if you
think about anxiety the way that
existentialist interpret anxiety in many
cases is a wareness of our own freedom
that realizes that we could screw up we
could screw up in ways that would be
catastrophic and Kierkegaard has the
example of the guy who stands at the
edge of the cliff and feels anxiety he
knows he's not going to throw himself
off because it would be stupid to do but
you never know maybe maybe I would do
that sort of thing right and I don't
think that Stoics would be immune to
that we are conscious of our own freedom
but if we understand that dynamic there
and we recognize the emotions as they're
coming up and and what they involve the
cognitive judgments that they they imply
we can sort of short-circuit them and
they won't go away entirely most likely
I don't they don't for me but we can
keep them from having the deciding voice
and what's going to happen so they're
not they're not influencing the pro' a
racist
the Faculty of choice or the ruling
principle if you like you know the other
term for that hegemony cone does that
that address it's officially a thinker
or not Greg did you want to respond to
that Greg Lopez just might indicate on
the chat or go off mute if not then we
will end here so yeah in a moment I'll
do some closing announcements but I
thought yeah I'll just say this that if
you want to practice your stoicism this
is this place of the Stowe is not going
to always be a place to kind of like
inquire into stones but we're gonna try
to develop an ecology of practices where
we can kind of like build this muscle of
fortitude and this is a collective we're
going to source the collective
intelligence to do this so if you have
any ideas let us know let me know so
before I make some closing announcements
Greg do you have any closing thoughts of
what what you're doing now where people
can find you oh well you know as I said
I'm on Twitter as philosopher 70 and you
know obviously my youtube channel just
Google and it'll it'll pop right up
reason IO is just reason io calm and I
do have you know a few other things here
and there and then I would say I am
editor of Stoicism today there's a lot
of a lot of great articles that we're
having coming in by guest authors so
modern stoicism coms where that's that's
cited otherwise yeah I mean and I think
what you're doing here is a really great
idea I actually have I'll talk with you
later I've got a few suggestions about
people you might have to bring into it
and yeah I don't have much more to say
very cool and I put all that information
of where to find more about Greg in the
chat box and make some announcement
about upcoming events but Greg thank you
my friend for coming in today that was a
very welcome and thanks everyone for
being on the call and giving the
excellent questions that you gave so we
have a bunch of events I think we have
like 16 lined up you can go on the
website
ww dot right in the chat box that's CA
and also going on the mailing list there
you can kind of get updates
you